very different than the biologist we're
doing different
stuff okay good afternoon everyone uh
Welcome to our third company of Scholars
lecture for this this uh Academic Year
uh this is our chance to hear from our
most distinguished and creative scholars
in our Y Community and hear about the
wonderful things they're doing hopefully
in a way that's accessible to a broad
range of interests in the room uh today
I am very pleased to have Nick
christakis here who will tell us about
social networks which from my naive
point of view means we've come here
together in this room to find out why
we're together here in this room um and
if I read some of his literature his
Publications right it may turn out that
we're all genetically linked I'm not
sure but I think we might be um so Nick
is the sa Goldman family professor of
Social and natural science in the
department of sociology and he also has
appointments in the Department of
Medicine ecology and evolutionary
biology and biomedical engineering so
this makes him a true citizen of our
campus I think I think he's covered just
about every school we have maybe you
need one in the law school anyway um uh
his background for a professor of
sociology is somewhat unusual after
graduating from Yale College he earned
both an MD and MPH degree from Harvard
and then he went to upen for his
residency and um decided that he the
next thing he needed was a PhD in
sociology which he earned at upen his
first faculty appointment was in the
sociology department at the University
of Chicago where he stayed for many
years and Rose to the rank of
Professor uh he then moved to Harvard in
2001 and was there until 2013 when he
joined the faculty at Yale he's received
numerous awards for his Innovative work
including a lection to The Institute of
Medicine of the National Academy of
Science he currently studies health and
social networks with a focus on how ill
health disability health behavior health
care and the end of life of a person
influenc inuences The Social Network
around that person and he's also
co-director of the Yale Institute for
Network science welcome thank you Lyn
thank you for having
[Applause]
me thank you very much for that kind
introduction and uh and thank you again
for having me so um most of the work I'm
going to be discussing today is joint
work I've done with my uh close friend
and collaborator James Fowler who's at
UCSD and I'd like to start with a set of
claims about uh human sociality and how
humans are connected to each other
briefly introduce some of the work we've
done on the evolutionary biology of
human social interactions to set the
stage for how a deeper understanding of
how humans are connected and why they're
connected then permits us to design
public health and other interventions in
a way that makes the world better so how
can we use a deep understanding of human
interactions to intervene in the world
to improve diverse outcomes whether it's
outcomes related to health Innovation
cooperation Civic engagement uh security
uh wealth production uh and so forth
because in fact humans are embedded in
social networks and these networks obey
very deep in fundamental mathematical
biological psychological and uh
sociological rules and principles and
taking this into account gives us a
chance to turbocharge behavioral
interventions such that as if we can
deliver them to particular individuals
in shrewd and tactical ways we can
actually lead to population level change
in all kinds of ways and in fact what it
can lead us to do is what I would like
to think of as a radical shift in public
health interventions so we begin to
think about not just how our
interventions affect the people to whom
we give our interventions but how our
we do not give our interventions how
people's embeddedness in networks allows
us to take a broader perspective a
broader view on how it is that
manipulating or intervening in the
social World creates spillover and
Cascade uh effects and in fact we can
use our understanding of social network
structure uh for good to advance good in
diverse sorts of ways actually this is a
kind of a dual use technology so during
the Q&A we can also talk about how you
can use the same ideas for bad but
that's another topic um so I'm
interested in real social networks the
kind we humans have been making uh and
embedding ourselves in for tens of
thousands probably hundreds of thousands
of years and not just the recent online
variety although I have something to say
about that as well so here is a typical
network sociogram uh every dot is a
person every line and it's hard to see
the lines unfortunately but every line
between the two dots represents a
relationship between two people and uh
and what's interesting is is that each
of us inherits our relatives but picks
our friends and our spouse uh picks our
co-workers our neighbors to some extent
and each of those people to whom we are
connected in turn is doing the same
thing and as a result of that we are
symble ourselves into this really ornate
structure this is to my eye the human
analogy of ant colonies so each person
is making these choices on an individual
level but as a result we give rise to a
greater whole and we proceed to live out
our lives and embedded in particular
locations within this graph and your
fate in life therefore comes to depend
not only on your own attributes not only
on your own decisionmaking your own
biology your own clinical circumstances
your own psychology and so forth but
also on the structure of the graph and
where you are in the network so
trivially for instance individuals that
are located here are going to be much
more likely to get communicable diseases
than individuals that are located here
quite aart from their immune system for
instance how their immune uh system is
performing or individuals who lose their
job and are here are going to be more
likely to be able to find a new job than
individuals over here quite apart from
their human capital education or other
attributes so where you are in the graph
can affect your fate in all kinds of
ways and to my eye these kinds of
networks are intricate things of beauty
and they are so elaborate and so complex
and so ubiquitous in fact that and they
have such a particular structure that
can be defined mathematically that it
has to be the case that their structure
and function is not a coincidence that
their must be in my judgment or my
opinion some reason we form networks
with this particular structure that we
can see here and in fact whenever human
social networks have been mapped they
always look strikingly similar so in the
upper left we have about 56 high school
students and who are their friends in
the upper right 105 college students and
who are their friends in the lower right
there are 400 people drawn from a sample
of 8 million people using NSA type
metadata on phone calls for a whole
nation you can map the social
interactions among all of these
individuals zoom in let's say on a group
of 400 and see who's calling who and you
can Define who's calling who in diverse
ways like very intense frequent calling
reciprocal calling and so forth to get a
sense of the social relationships
between people and so that's 400 people
there and on the lower left is a
scientific co-authorship Network
scientists collaborating with each other
and all of these networks look visually
the same and in fact mathematically can
be Quantified and shown to be plausibly
extremely uh similar and this
consistency raises the possibility ility
that we evolve to have networks and to
have networks with a very particular
structure and our lab has been amassing
evidence that it is indeed not a
coincidence that we form networks with
particular properties and we've been
been able to show or find suggestive
evidence for an evolutionary
significance to andh heritability of
social network structure and function
and that phenomena like homop for
instance the fact that we prefer the
company of people we resemble I mean ask
yourselves this it's widely known since
Plato at least that people prefer the
company of people they resemble uh and
to my eye most explanations for this
phenomena nowadays or until recently
have been relatively tological so you
ask let's say psychologists why do
people prefer the company of people they
resemble they say well people are more
comfortable in the presence of people
they resemble why are they more
they resemble because they resemble them
it's a kind of a circular argument it
doesn't in my judgment get to the heart
of the matter which is well why why do
we feel this affinity for individuals
that we resemble and other properties of
social networks like peer influence you
know why why as a species do we evince
social learning why are we affected uh
by others and there many many thoughts
that go back quite a long time uh in
this regard but my general point is is
that these these thoroughgoing
observations about our social life that
we prefer the company of people we
resemble that we're influenced by them
that people have a taste for friendship
for instance or ask yourself this why do
we have friends at all I mean other
species don't form long-term
non-reproductive unions to other members
of their species it's actually
exceedingly rare in the Kingdom that we
evince this property of of having
long-standing friendships with specific
identifiable other individuals so um so
all these things we take for granted in
large measure I think have very
fundamental uh explanations and
understanding those explanations then
which I'm only going to briefly review
today uh serves as a predicate for
Designing interventions that I think can
be beneficial in diverse uh sorts of
ways and I guess the most summary
statement I would make about the
evolutionary uh role of networks is that
it must be the case I think that a cross
evolutionary time the benefits of a
connected life must outweigh the costs
so coming near other people exposes us
to certain risks of infection of
violence of misinformation and so forth
but also coming near them gives us
certain opportunities and the calculus
across time must be that it's beneficial
to us to connect with others in in
particular
ways well one of the things we did One
initial paper we did a few years ago
looked at the so-called heritability of
network uh position and um and so one of
the things and this sets the stage for a
number of other ideas we'll be
discussing today is a very basic sort of
primer on social network position so
here's a typical network of real people
and their friendships and the thing you
need to appreciate about this is that
there are different structural positions
within the graph so that for example
individual B has four connections these
are friendships among these people an
individual D has six connections and
this is known as the degree of a node
and people vary in their degree some
people have four friends some people
have six friends some people have no
friends people know how many friends
they have but there are other attributes
of people's position within the graph
that they might not necessarily be able
to appreciate for instance consider
nodes c and d c has six friends and so
does d and if you talk to them this
might be the limit of their
understanding of their their social life
I have six friends you have six friends
but we with this bird's eyee view can
see that there's a difference between
the two and I can cultivate this
intuition In You by asking you who would
you rather be if a deadly germ was
spreading through the netor work C or D
D right you have the intuition that D is
going to be less likely to get whatever
spreading and less likely to get it
early in the course of the epidemic
conversely who would you rather be if a
juicy piece of Gossip were spreading
through the network C and this this can
be Quantified mathematically it's the
centrality of a node and there are
different kinds of ways this can be done
using igen vector centrality or between
a centrality and the same kind of
mathematics is is that the core of
Google's page rank algorithm that serves
up Pages the magic of Google is that
when it's given a set of pages that
features a topic Pages at the top are
the ones that are more like C and less
like d finally if you look at nodes A
and B A and B have both have four
connections but the difference between
the two is that the friend of a friend
of A's is back again a friend of A's the
friend of a friend of A's is back again
a friend of A's whereas the friend of a
friend of B's is not a friend of be's so
now imagine that you were a prehistoric
human and you were going out to kill a
maedon and you wanted to get a bunch of
people together to go kill the damn
thing uh who would you rather be do you
think A or
B A want to get your tight neck group of
friends together to cooperate go out and
kill the madon but if the challenge was
not to kill the Mastadon but rather to
find the Mastadon you would rather be B
because the redundancy of information is
much higher in a than b do you know
where the Mastadon is no do you know
where the Mastadon is your friend's
friend is your friend comes right back
to you whereas in the case of B you can
reach further into the graph to bring
back information for instance about the
location of predators or prey these are
very stylized very quick set of toy uh
illustrations of some of the ideas but
the basic point is that different
positions within the network can be
Quant are different and can be
Quantified in various specific ways and
one study we did that was published now
five years ago looked at the extent to
which each of those three traits and
others which I'm not going into today uh
can are seen as heritable so on the y-
axis is the percent of the variance
that's explained or the heritability of
these traits and on the x-axis is these
three traits and on the far left is the
number of connections or the degree of a
node and what this slide says is that
46% of the variation in how many friends
people have can be explained by their
genes now this is not a shocking result
people vary in their taste for
friendship some of us are shy some
people are gregarious that people would
have variation in this is not a big
surprise but we also found that these
higher order properties of network
structure also seem to vary and 47% of
the transitivity uh which is that other
difference between a and b no can is
also heritable and this is one of the
more bizarre results that come out of
our lab in the last few years because
what I've just told you is that if you
have Tom Dick and Harry in a room
whether dick is friends with Harry
depends not just on Dick's jeans or on
Harry's jeans but on Tom's jeans whether
you two guys are friends with each other
depends on her genes how can that
be well we think the reason is that
people vary in their tendency to
introduce their friends to each other
some people knit the network around them
together and some keep the network
separate and apart and have a difference
in this tendency and finally even 29% of
the variation in how Central you are in
the network can also be explained by
your genes so we've done more work in
this area but the general kind of
summary I would give is that this
fundamental reality of our desire for
connection and is consequently our
susceptibility to certain kinds of
social influence it turns out has always
been with us and where you are in this
vast fabric of humanity Can Depend in
part on your genes
now if it's the case that Network
structure has genetic antecedence and
evolutionary significance it begs the
question of how ancient this structure
is and whether we could document such
structural features in human populations
living in non-m modernized settings so
our fantasy here was well if you could
go back 10,000 years and look at humans
in the pene could you find evidence that
the networks they made were the same as
our networks guided as it were by this
sort of fundamental biology that is
within us obviously we can't do that but
we hit upon the idea of instead mapping
the social networks of a human
population that lives like we did 10,000
years ago specifically the Hoda Hunter
gathers of Tanzania this is one of the
last remaining Hunter gather populations
on the planet they um they hunt and they
gather for their food they sleep out
under the stars they have very limited
material possessions to speak of every
six weeks they move around they're
natural fertility population and uh and
there are 17 camps uh in Hiland arranged
around Lake aasi about 300,000 square
kilometers so one of my post STS who had
some experience there and Frank Marlo
one of the leading ethnographers of the
hza collaborated with us to do this
project and what we did is and there
only about a thousand of them left only
about a thousand hza left only about
half of those are adults and what we did
is is we made a photographic census of
all living adult hza a kind of hza
Facebook and we took this these posters
into the field and uh and then we asked
every adult hza we could find to
identify their friends in different
sorts of ways and when then we studied
this network and other kinds of features
of hodza life in all kinds of ways but
the bottom line for today is that what
we found is that mathematically and
Visually hza social networks look just
like ours so despite the fact that in
the intervening 10,000 years we've
invented agriculture we've invented
cities we've invented telepan the social
networks that we make look just like the
social networks that the hodza made in a
very different kind of evolutionarily
relevant uh environment in addition
while we were there we got the hanza to
play what is known as a public goods
game we got them to we tested how
Cooperative they were how willing they
were to collaborate with others by
giving them uh honey sticks and and
asking them whether they wanted to
donate honey sticks to their neighbors
and if the neighbors would reciprocate
in all kinds of ways I won't go into but
as a result we were able to quantify how
altruistic each respondent was and
that's shown by the dot size and color
here the red dots are the defectors
they're really you know the lousy guys
that take advantage of their neighbors
the yellow dots are the kind sort of
altruists here and the orange dots or in
between and what we find is that hza
cooperativity clusters in the graph in
certain very specific and actually we
think highly relevant uh ways because it
turns out that it is much easier for
cooperation and other valuable phenomena
to emerge and be sustained when people
can control the structure of their
networks as we'll see in a little bit
and it turns out that that there's a
deep relationship between actually
between goodness and social networks so
so we then also while we were there
looking at this question of what is the
graph structure of the Hoda networks we
also evaluated certain ideas we had
about the role that Network structure
might play in the in the collective
expression of desirable properties like
information flow immunity uh Collective
immunity and uh and
cooperation now a lot of the work that
we had done have done which I'm not
showing you today used as observational
methods where we study using statistical
and econometric techniques different
sorts of uh graphs but we've also over
the last few years begun to do some
experiments which is the main focus of
today's uh talk because these
experiments have allowed us to get
around some of the difficult uh issues
of causal inference using observational
data but they also give us Exquisite
control over some of the phenomena we
want to study and in particular we
become progressively more interested in
the pro-social functions of networks and
so our experiments also allow us to not
only address the methodologic issue of
causal inference but also to focus down
on certain specific things we're
interested in which is how networks are
used used for good good ends this is one
experiment that we published a few years
ago in this example college students
were brought into the laboratory they
were strangers to each other they were
given a little bit of money that they
could play with and they were invited to
contribute the money uh and they were
randomly assigned into groups of four
and they could contribute the money to
the common good and if they did that the
researcher would multiply the money and
then the money would be divided across
all four individuals so the individual
pays a price but there's a net benefit
to the group from the point of view of
Any Given individual what they should do
is defect like sort of be a be a free
rider on every hope everyone else
cooperates and contributes to the common
good but they do nothing they'll make
the most money that way but of course if
everyone does that then the group you
have a tragedy of the commons the group
collapses and of course the group does
best if everyone cooperates and
contributes to the collective good so
that was the setup in this experiment
and then what would happen is a bell
would ring and people would be randomly
assigned to new partners and then a bell
would ring and they'd be randomly
assigned to new partners and so forth
and so on for six rounds and so what we
were able therefore to do is to
reconstruct social networks and explore
a topic which hadn't previously been
explored so what was interesting to us
here is not if I am kind to Lynn does
Lynn reciprocate the kindness a kind of
direct reciprocity nor which has been
widely studied and is actually also a
difficult topic nor were we interested
so much in the topic of indirect
reciprocity which is if I am kind to
Lynn is Steven then kind to me perhaps
Steven sees I'm a kind kind of guy
expects me to reciprocate to him perhaps
he wants to reward me for my kindness to
Lynn that's indirect reciprocity what we
were interested in is if I'm kind to
Lynn is she then kind to Steven uh and
is is Steven then kind to you is there a
kind of a spreading process in the
network such that we could show a kind
of social contagion of altruistic
Behavior here experimentally and that's
exactly what we were able to show what
we were able to show is that if elenia
is kind to Lucas in Period one Lucas is
kind to Erica in Period two Erica is
kind to Jay in Period 3 and Jay is kind
to Breen in period four a kind of GE
desic spread of altruism in this network
and this is another very bizarre result
that come out of our lab in the last few
years because what I've just told you is
that how Jay treats Breen depends on how
aleni treated Lucas even though neither
Jay nor Breen ever interacted with a
lenar Lucas here shown in an
experimental setting where we have
Exquisite control over the topology of
the network and the interactions between
the individuals and this geodesic spread
of kindness is different from the
temporal Persistence of kindness such
that if alen is kind to Lucas in Period
one Lucas learns to be kind and goes on
to be kind to Erica in Period two and
Lysander in Period 3 and b in period
four and so forth in fact if you fold
back all the downstream kindness acre
for every extra dollar a Lenny gives
Lucas the network functions as a kind of
matching Grant doubling the downstream
benefits to the population a conditional
on the structure of the graph here a
structure we cause experimentally but of
course naturally we make different kinds
of structures so pay it forward is real
in this situation
yeah I'm not following this logic
completely yeah I'm moving very fast I
apologize because this is sort of a
preamble believe it or not to where I
actually want to go today but yes what
go ahead yeah how do you know they would
have uh donated or
been kind to each other without this
initial so in this case control in other
words okay so in this case uh in this
case what we're doing is is we're
controlling the sequence of interactions
so it's not as if I induce you to be
very kind and him counterfactually to
not be kind so people behave naturally
how they're want to do but we control
the sequence of their interactions and
examine if you chose to be kind in the
first period what happens thereafter and
if he chose not to be kind in the first
period what happens thereafter both
kindness and unkindness spread but for
various reasons I don't want to go into
right now kindness outstrips uh the
spread of unkindness and the net result
of which is that for every extra dollar
the first guy chooses to give the
network the Ripple effects that we
discern so this is a study trying to
quantif ify and observe the Ripple
effects so I could imagine putting you
in a room with someone and seeing how do
you act are you nice or not fine but
then I could also ask well gee what
happens if he's nice or unkind are how
far does it spread in the graph are
there Ripples and this was the purpose
of this study was to see those Ripples
and and quantify them other studies I'll
show you in a moment do other
manipulations to do the try to achieve
the following objective say you're
unkind can I put you in a graph with a
structure and other features other
design features that make you mind can I
control your behavior by structurally
manipulating the nature of your
interactions and I'll show you some
experiments to that effect in a moment
other
questions
um so using observational and
experimental methods we and others have
provided evidence that a variety of
behaviors and phenomena spread within
networks uh via social contagion so
obesity smoking drinking and drug use
Behavior emotional states like happiness
loneliness depression I just showed you
one little experiment with altruism uh
crime Andrew papac Christos here at
Harvard is doing some beautiful work on
crime and its spread voting behavior
I'll show you that in just a moment
purchasing behavior and ideas so
different kinds of behaviors spread in
graphs via processes of social contagion
and in fact people's attitudes decisions
and behaviors depend in quantifiable
ways on the attitudes decisions and
behaviors of others around them and in
fact a key idea about networks is that
they magnify whatever they are seated
with networks magnify whatever they are
seated with but they must be seated they
don't on their own Su generous give rise
to phenomena some external Force must
impinge which gets the process started
like an epidemic and then the network
takes over and makes more of whatever it
is the thing that you introduced into
the graph and in fact uh to to ouri one
of the sort of deep purposes of networks
is to function as a kind of social
magnifying glass and we begun to think
about how to exploit this magnification
property and other fundamental
observations about netork structure in
order to maximize our ability to induce
Behavior change with interventions in
populations by exploiting this
understanding of how networks form and
operate now to be clear we're affected
in another way by networks as well it's
not just what's happening around us
whether the people around us are
behaving altruistically or gaining
weight for instance that matters the
actual structure of the network also
matters so think about these two objects
that we all studied in high school in
high school chemistry as we all know
they're both made of carbon but the
difference between the two is that on
the left you have graphite which is soft
and dark and on the right you have
Diamond which is hard and clear and this
originates in the difference to how the
carbon atoms are connected to each other
you take the carbon atoms and you
connect them one way you get graphite
which is soft and dark connect them
another way you get diamond which is
hard and clear and there are two key
ideas here about these allotropes of
carbon first these properties of
softness and darkness and hardness and
clearness are not properties of the
carbon atoms they're properties of the
collection of carbon atoms and second
which properties you get depends on how
you connect the carbon atoms to each
other connect them one way you get one
set of properties connect them another
way you get a different set of
properties and similarly the pattern of
our connections in social networks can
give the group properties that are not
present within the individuals
properties which can vary conditional on
how you connect the same human beings to
each other connect them one way one set
of properties connect them another way
different set of properties it's the
ties between people that make the whole
greater than the sum of its parts and
new properties can emerge because of the
connections because of the ties between
people and not necessarily because of
the people themselves so it's not just
what's happening in the people around us
that matters uh it's the structure of
the graph that can also
matter now these sorts of observations
suggest two broad ways to intervene in
networks uh for good to enhance a public
health and public policy uh in a variety
of ways and the two Broadways are to
manipulate connection to to change the
structure of the graph who knows who to
experiment or manipulate the topology or
to manipulate contagion given a certain
structure given a pattern of
interactions between people who do you
target let's say with information or if
you're a terrorist who do you infect so
that you get the maximum bang like which
one person should you infect to really
infect the whole population this would
be a kind of contagion intervention
given a particular structure and there's
expanding science um in both areas so
I'm going to show you some experiments
with some applications to positive
outcomes that we and others have been
doing now this is one of my favorite
illustrations of this idea it takes a
minute to set this up but I think the
payoff is really worth
it this was work done by a former postto
of mine while he was in our lab using a
experimental platform that we've
developed that allows us to recruit
people from around the world and come in
and participate in experiments of
varying duration in a virtual laboratory
real people in a virtual online lab lab
and in this situation what we did is is
we created two different worlds in which
people would be dropped into a world on
the left and the world on the right in
both of these worlds there were
precisely 128 people and there were
multiple replicates of this but I'm just
speaking as if there were two worlds
there were many variants of there were
multiple replicates of each of these two
worlds in each of these two worlds are
128 people and in each of these worlds
every single person is connected to
precisely six other people so for
example here this yellow dot is
connected to these six red people and
here this yellow dot is connected to
these six red dots over here and if you
talk to people in these worlds I would
say to you how many people in your world
128 how many in yours 128 how many
friends do you have six how many friends
do you have six how many friends do your
friends have they all have six friends
didto for you and yet the structure of
the network is completely different and
we with this bird's eye view can now see
that the structure is different and the
question is does this structure affect
what happens to the group net of the
individuals now it used to be thought so
if I asked you let's say you can infect
this individual here with a germ or this
individual do you have intuitions into
in which of these worlds the pathogen
will spread more rapidly and more
completely the the left Network or the
right Network the left Network yeah
because in the first time step the
yellow dot infects the six red dots in
the next time step it infects all the
other dots that he knows the network
flushes you get the whole population is
evincing the epidemic whereas on the
right the the epidemic has to spread in
a very plotting way way slowly across
the graph before it reaches the other
side and the same kind of thing of
course happens with information spread
so the Dynamics of information flow
would be better in the left than on the
right and it used to be thought that
everything spread better in random
networks than in neighborhood networks
but it turns out that only things that
spread by so-called simple contagion
spread better in random networks than in
uh neighborhood networks things that
spread by so-called complex contagion
spread better in networks with the
structure on the right for example
consider the idea of smoking cessation
imagine these are smokers on an online
uh site where we're trying to get people
to quit smoking and you persuade the
yellow dot to quit smoking here on the
left hand side this guy might have some
weak effect on these six uh individuals
but each of those individuals is now
surrounded by other smokers so his
ability to manifest the behavior to
which he's just been exposed is
attenuated by the presence nearby of
other people who are still smokers
whereas here this individual affects
these six people and it creates a
Frontier where each of these people on
the frontier is connected to two 3 four
five or six other people who've just
quit smoking so smoking sensation
spreads like a wave in the network on
the right but extinguishes in the left
same with cooperation if you persuade
this guy to be cooperative he might have
some weak effect on these guys but
they're all surrounded by defectors who
take advantage of them whereas here you
can get a kind of Cooperative wave that
spreads through the graph and
furthermore to cultivate an intuition in
you about the difference between these
two I could show you that you can
convert this graph to to this graph by
manipulating a single parameter for
example imagine you cut these two ties
and those two ties and rewired the two
ties across creating a shortcut across
the middle that actually preserves the
degree distribution everyone's still
connected to six people and so forth but
you should have the intuition that now
if the germ reaches here it can skip
right across to the other side and in
fact by repeatedly iteratively cutting
and uh pairs of ties and rewiring the
network at random eventually you convert
this graph to that graph so the two can
be manipulated in this fash
but the point is is that different
things spread differently in the two
networks so you now could live in one of
these two worlds and the same individual
in these two worlds could have very
different Fates in one world the world
is organized in a way that makes you
quit smoking and uh and um and uh be
cooperative and be less susceptible to
infections or to the spread of
information and in the other world it's
precisely the opposite so this group
level property it's like the carbon
atoms it's like softness and darkness
and hardness and clearness the social
graph gives the groups properties that
transcend the individual elements within
the graph here shown experimentally by
manipulating the connections and
watching and seeing what happens uh in
ways I won't go elaborate that uh what's
done in this uh
paper so this would be a connection
intervention I could take for example a
group of Engineers that work in a firm
and say how can I make these Engineers
more or less inventive or I can take a
group of students and try to get them to
uh quit smoking or be nicer to each
other how can I manipulate their graph
how can I wire arrange the ties between
them in a fashion that makes them behave
better in different sorts of ways
through a manipulation that controls the
topology of the
network another experiment that we've
done that we just published a couple
years ago looks at another kind of
regime where we manipulate Connection in
this experiment we did the following
thing we took individuals and we dropped
them into an Uris Renu random graph
which was initiated by us so we we we
specify using a sort of mathematical
process a um a graph a topology a
structure of the network and then we
take people and we drop them into
specific locations within the graph and
we have them play a public goods game
with their neighbors just the people
around them like the public goods game I
described earlier and here in this graph
in this regime the red dots are the
defectors and the blue dots are the
Cooperators and here people are dropped
into a graph where they're stuck with
the neighbors that we picked and they
can in the first round they cooperate or
effect and what we find across time in a
in a world in which people have no
control over their social ties is that
cooperation disappears from the system
you're initially a cooperator you're
stuck with all these defectors you say
to hell with that and you switch to
defection yourself so by the end
everyone becomes a Defector cooperation
is not sustained in a network which has
this topological regime on the bottom
and this was a result previously
theorized uh by many others and
experimentally shown by many others uh
in the past so so we replicate that
result but then in the top we add a
wrinkle in the top we give people an
additional option so not only can they
choose whether to cooperate or defect
but at every time step we give them the
opportunity to cut ties to people who
are defectors and to form ties to people
who are Cooperators actually they could
also form ties to defectors if they
wanted we don't specify but we give them
a little control over their social
structure and in this type of a world we
find that cooperation persists in a
world in which we give people not only
the ability to reciprocate not only to
evince behavioral reciprocity but also
to evince thae reciprocity where they
can manipulate the structure of their
Network we can create a world in which
people um uh behave better so I can take
you guys and by specifying one set of
rules of interaction make you mean sons
of to each other or I can take
you guys and specify a different rule of
interaction I can make the same people
kind and nice to each other by
controlling not who you are but how you
interact with each other here shown
experimentally in subsequent experiments
that I'm not going to present today we
explored the parameter space we saw we
explored how much rewiring is optimal to
create uh optimal cooperation in social
groups based on some theory of that
other people have done that suggests
that actually it should be parabolic
that there's a too much rewiring and too
little rewiring and that it's the middle
range of rewiring the middle range of
social mutability that optimizes
cooperation in human
groups yeah so this shows in this
particular experiment we had four uh
there were I don't know a couple
thousand subjects in this experiment we
had four different treatments this is
the fraction of Cooperative players at
the beginning here's the round of game
play this is sort of time over an hour
or so on the on the x- axis uh here is
the fixed Network in green everyone
starts at around 60% cooperation and
over time you know the green line shows
a decline in cooperation and here I
showed you the so-called fluid Dynamic
uh situation in which people are allowed
some dynamism in their Network and
cooperation persists across time and we
explor explored how much dynamism was
needed also allowing a viscous Dynamic
situation and then cooperation
disappears if there's not enough
fluidity uh in the social
ties so those are a couple of
experiments
illustrating how you can um manipulate
the wiring the topology of a network and
get groups to behave differently uh in
in desirable ways let me show you a
couple of experiments is any questions
so
far
yeah Dynamic was it like after only
certain rounds or they could only choose
one person yeah so we had a number of
ways of doing that uh the gist of it was
we uh we uh the mechanics were at any
given round uh the computer did an
inventory of all existing ties picked in
in the in the fluid Dynamic a simple
random sample of 30% of the ties whether
they were of all possible ties so there
were you know 20 people so they're 20 *
19 divided by two possible ties some of
which exist some of which do not so
there couplets on either side of those
ties and then with 30% probability
couplets that were joined one person was
chosen at random and asked you want to
cut the tie and couplets that didn't
exist one person was chosen at random
and said you want to form a tie and so
that at every round that what was what
happened and then in subsequent
experiments we manipulated whether it
was 10% or 20 or 30 or 100% of the ties
were up for grabs at any given
time other
questions so this is another set of
experiments in which now we are kind of
this is our sort of a more public
healthy kind of work we're doing uh so
imagine now for example that um that you
have uh this is a paradigmatic example
that you have sets of villages in the
developing world and you go and you map
the networks of these Villages so you
have the village on the left and The
Village on the right and then uh and
then you you choose six people at random
in this right- hand Village the yellow
dots and you target them for a public
health intervention you know a clean
water intervention or a polio
vaccination intervention and the conven
itional Public Health point of view on
this topic is that you give these people
the intervention and you come back a
year later and you see what fraction of
the six people adopted the intervention
maybe three of the six adopted the
intervention but my interest our
interest is not so much in whether the
people to whom you gave the intervention
responded but rather what did all the
other people in the village do when you
gave these six people the intervention
so maybe six of these three people were
given the intervention three adopted but
they recruited three of their friends
total of six people in this Village uh
evinced the desirable Public Health
intervention whereas in the control
Village that didn't get the intervention
perhaps by secular change two people
adopted this new clean water practice or
whatever it is so the difference between
six and two gives you an estimate of the
pure peer effects under control uh in
this um uh
situation but with this sort of Paradigm
now we can begin to imagine kind of more
inventive ways of choosing these six
people maybe instead of picking them at
random we might pick six central people
six people that have these these
particular attributes of being in a
structurally influential we might might
imagine location within the graph now
perhaps of these six people again three
of them might adopt but they might
recruit 30 of their friends and on the
left again two in the control Village
same Villages same number of people same
intervention 10 times the impact because
now we've picked individuals who are
structurally influential it's not what's
important to us in this case is not
attributes of the individuals if they're
tall or short or rich or poor but where
they are in the graph that we need to
Define and then pick them and Target
them using algorithms that people like
Dan Spielman and others at Yin are
inventing so we take some of that
technology and we say okay what does the
mathematics of networks tell us about
who should have the biggest impact if we
were going to rationally Target uh
individuals uh in the
network and there's another way that
this could be done because um one of the
one of our interests is we don't want to
just invent research tools for
understanding how to change population
Behavior we want to invent tools that
people could actually use in the real
life uh developing World settings things
and so mapping networks is expensive and
time consuming so we would ideally like
a way of identifying structurally
influential individuals without having
to map uh the network especially if
mapping is not
feasible in particular also because
mapping is not scalable so the question
is can we identify structurally
influential people without having to map
the network of the whole population and
it turns out that there is a
mathematical fact about social networks
that's known as the Friendship Paradox
that can be summarized by the
observation that your friends have more
friends than you do did you know this
your friends have more friends than you
do actually your sexual partners have
more sexual partners and you do too and
your and your co-authors have more
co-authors than you do and this is just
a general property of social networks
the average person in a graph has Mew
friends but the average friend of the
average person has Mew plus the variance
divided by Mew friends so if there's
heterogen aan degree if people vary in
the number of friends they have the
average person has the average number of
friends but the average friend of a
average person has higher number and in
the limiting condition you can imagine
that uh that if everyone had the same
number of friends then your friends
would have as many friends as you do and
if there's a a lot of extreme skewness
to the distribution there might be one
person who has many friends and that
also illustrates the point for instance
imagine that there is a party host that
has a party and has a hundred friends
and invites all of them to the party and
each of those people have no friends you
got 101 people in the room and now you
sample from those people and you ask
them uh who is your friend 100 people
would name their party host and that
party host has 100 friends so for a
hundred of the people in this extremely
skewed distribution their friends would
have more friends than they did only
when you picked a party host would their
friend have fewer friends than they do
so on average your friends would have
more friends than you do I can
furthermore cultivate this intuition by
asking you to consider the edge
conditions so for instance look at the
people on the periphery of the network
this person has only one friend that's
why they're on the edge but by
construction that friend must have more
friends than they do must have two
friends so everyone on the edge has more
F their friends have more friends than
they do and in fact that same intuition
holds all the way through the graph that
on average if you pick the yellow dots
at random and ask them to nominate their
friends their friends will have more
friends than they do and the reason this
is extraordinarily useful and valuable
is that you can take this idea and then
identify structurally influential people
without mapping the graph you pick
people at random in the population ask
them to nominate their friends and you
give the treatment to the friend of the
random people not to the people that
you've picked themselves so we use this
idea as well in the experiment I'm about
to show
you because we've been doing field
experiments of network targeting in
diverse locations around the world in
Honduras a site where we send about a
half dozen yeles or more about eight
yeles this past summer uh in our site in
uh in lmir in Honduras with a vitamin
and water purification intervention in
Uganda with HIV treatment in India we
just finished a project on polio
treatment online I I showed you some
experiments and we've also been doing
some work on diffusion of innovation in
physician uh networks this is the region
where we work in
Honduras it's a very poor about $2 a day
uh population in Highland Honduras it's
a coffee growing region there are these
little compact Villages that have an
average of two or 3 hundred people that
live in them and they're separated one
Village uh from another uh it looks like
this and uh and what we did is is we
mapped the networks for 32 Villages uh
in this area right now we're also
beginning to do a project where we're
mapping 160 villages in a different area
of Honduras uh and we mapped these
Villages and then what we did is we did
a randomized trial in which we took
onethird of The Villages and we picked
5% of the people in each of those
Villages and gave them a couple of inter
Public Health interventions so clean
water chlorine intervention and a
multivitamin intervention in another
third of the villages we picked uh 5% of
the people who had the highest in degree
who had the most friends and in a third
third of the villages we picked 5% of
the people using the Friendship Paradox
idea so we picked people at random and
then we uh for each person we picked at
random we went one step at random in the
graph and picked that individual instead
and then to all those 5% in each Village
we delivered a uh Public Health uh
intervention and our question was can we
move a whole village and not just
individuals to change their
behavior given a budget constraint who
do we target who creates the most
externalities for Behavior change so if
we get if we put all our and getting
these 5% of people to to do something
better can we change attitudes towards
latrine adoption in India or polio
vaccination in Pakistan or or HIV
treatment in Uganda like how do we get
people to change their minds about
something by picking individuals not on
their own attributes but but where they
are in the graph so this illustrates two
of the targeting algorithms in one
Village so for example the N the uh the
ingree targets look like they're ingree
they're more to the center the yellow
targets and the random targets here are
shown uh in Orange um and here's one of
my graduate students uh Alison hang in
the Red Cap delivering the intervention
this was two or three years ago now this
is the Clorox intervention uh and here
are the results uh of of the study uh
here on the y- AIS is the proportion
adopting the Clean Water intervention uh
and the and the colored lines indicate
and on the x-axis and I'm sorry on the
on the x-axis is time since targeting
and what we find is is that there's no
difference by targeting algorithm for
the Florine
intervention but by the multivitamin
intervention we find that ingree
targeting the nomination targeting
technique uh works the most so you can
start with a 5% targeting and you get
nearly 75% adoption of vitamin uh
practice uh over the course of a couple
of weeks using the nomination targeting
uh Technique we have many similar
results which I won't go into uh and we
have some ideas as to why there's a
difference between these two types of
interventions this type of experimental
work is still at early days in public
health and my hope and expectation is
that over the coming decade as more and
more people try to use Network methods
to see how to change Behavior at scale
we'll be able to get more generalizable
knowledge about why some things work
this way and some don't so right now we
think that part of the reason for this
has to do with a complex and simple
contagion idea that vitamin
interventions might spread by simple
contagion but changing the way you clean
your water might require reinforcement
for from those around you so that
there's not a lot of difference not a
lot of bang for the buck to be gained by
different targeting algorithms uh in
this type of a
situation here's another experiment that
was done by James fower many of you
probably un unbeknownst to you may have
participated in this experiment this was
a randomized control trial the largest
ever done 61 million people uh in the
election four years ago were randomly
assigned if they were a Facebook user on
Election Day uh four or five years four
or six years ago uh you were you were
shown a uh little Banner on the top of
your Facebook page that said today is
election day find find your polling
place in the US you can you can click
here and find your polling place and you
can click a button that says whether you
voted or not so far on that day and the
experimental manipulation involved
showing people whether or not their
friends had also clicked on that button
so the stim the experimental
manipulation was revealing to you did
your friends Vote or not to try to see
could we induce Cascades of Civic uh
mindedness of Civic engagement by
manipulating the exposure to information
about whether someone's uh people of
voted or not and an important feature in
this experiment is because whether you
vote or not is a public record who you
vote for is obviously not public but
whether you vote is many millions of
these people were also linked to their
actual real life data so we could link
uh Facebook click the I voted button to
did you actually vote to actually get
ground Truth uh in this situation and
there's a lot of results in this paper
but the bottom line was that uh this is
the increase in the in the number of
validated votes uh because of the direct
effect of exposing the individual so
let's say an extra 50,000 people voted
as a result of this experiment uh and
they in turn influenced their friends
now we could trace out the social
contagion in the experiment Now
experimentally by seeding individuals
with the intervention an extra 300,000
people who were close friends of those
individuals also voted there's actually
a lot more in this experiment but one of
the things that pleases me the most
about this experiment is this this was a
scientific experiment conducted on a
single day with a weak a very we
stimulus just showing people a little
Banner on their Facebook page whether or
not they voted and that simple little
experiment which was not done to improve
our Civic democracy got 350,000 extra
people to turn out to the polls on that
day there's a scientist doing a project
that gets more Americans hundreds of
thousands of more Americans to go out
and vote with a really trivial uh
intervention of just showing them did
your friends Vote or not and many of you
probably have the experience of
traveling in a hotel and are probably
familiar with the famous results that
show that the way you're more likely to
recycle your towels is not by an
intervention that a little card in the
bathroom that says you know uh recycle
your towel you know keep using your
towels Save the Planet but actually a
little intervention that says 75% of
previous inhabitants of this room uh
also uh you know uh kept their towels
for their whole stay and actually that's
very powerful people you know keep their
towels for the stay don't throw them on
the
ground now um
uh so we can exploit these ideas uh to
enhance the responsive behavioral
interventions as I've been saying both
amongst the untreated and among the
treated we can use it to deliberately
create spillovers and uh uh and to sort
of reinforce the spread amongst the
untreated but we can also use these
ideas to reinforce the behavior among
the treated by trying to get people who
are doing something good to be
surrounded by other people who are doing
the same good thing to provide for them
to uh to keep doing it and depending on
how you do this we estimate that often
you can quadruple the return on
investment from public health
interventions by uh taking advantage of
this type of a network effect so people
are connected and so their health and
their behaviors are connected now how
much time do I have left I don't know
till when we go so it's eight minutes
till 5 and we'd love to have time for
questions sure and when are we supposed
to end around about five oh around five
okay because I had been told 5:30 and
that's obviously wrong so um okay so I'm
going to skip another experimental
result that we had and I'm just going to
close then uh with one so I had one
other experiment I was going to show you
which involved not delivering
information into the network but
extracting information from the network
using uh some of the ideas we've been
discussing but that'll be another time
so I want to close with one big idea
having to do with what it means when we
intervene in a social network because I
think such interventions provide us with
a way to manipulate social capital and
in order to understand this we have to
consider the following
idea what's the point of a connected
life how does it help us as individuals
and as a species and it turns out that
networks are a resource that we can all
use networks are a kind of Social
Capital now most people when they think
about Capital think about
money but really capital is any stock of
resources any stock of resources that
can be put to productive use that you
can do something with and to further key
ideas about Capital are that in order to
create Capital you have to invest skill
and effort you have to know something
and do something to produce capital and
second and much more interesting and
much more subtle as far as I'm concerned
is that in order to create Capital
really what you have to do is you have
to make changes in a substance that make
it yield a higher rate of return than it
otherwise would that on the deepest
level what capital creation is about is
the transmutation of the natural world
that makes the transmuted thing more
productive than it was before for
example a farm is a stock of capital you
can take a forest you can invest skill
and effort you can transmute the natural
world and you get a farm and the farm is
more valuable than the forest because
you can do things with a farm you
couldn't do with a forest namely grow
fruits and vegetables and Grains and
flowers for instance and that what
that's what makes it a reservoir of
wealth and a source of productive power
is this transmutation uh when you
transmute the farm of the forest into
the for into the farm so improved land
is a form of
capital or you can imagine taking this
tree and you invest skill and effort and
you transmute it into Lumber and the
lumber is more valuable than the tree
because you can do things with a lumber
you couldn't do with a tree such as
invest still more skill and effort and
convert it to a violin and the violin is
more valuable than the lumber because
you can do things with a violin you
couldn't do with a lumber and at every
step of the way you invest skill and
effort you transmute the natural world
and you make something that is a stock
of productive power so capital is a
change that allows a substance to act in
new ways and this is part of what makes
it a store of wealth and a source of
productive power now a key Innovation
took place in so among social scientists
in the 1960s to begin to think about
human beings in this fashion so you can
take this dissolute former graduate
student of mine on the left who's a
drunkard and you can invest skill and
effort and send him to Alcoholics
Anonymous and clean him up and now he
becomes more productive and able to do
things he wasn't previously able to do
or you can invest still more skill and
effort and give him a Yale or actually
here a Colombia education and uh and you
can make him still more productive you
can change his mind you can work upon
the neurons of his brain and now he
becomes a reservoir of wealth you've
transmuted the natural world and you've
imbued the transmuted object with
properties that didn't exist before and
this is what we mean by Capital
production well just like physical
capital is cre created by a change in
the material world and human capital by
a change in persons social capital in
organizations and companies and
communities in fact in our whole society
is a change in the relations among
persons a change that renders the group
more productive and capable of doing
things it was not previously able to do
thank you very
much
can you just repeat questions yeah you
want me to repeat questions okay who you
want you want call in people or you want
me to no you please go ahead okay
Stephen Nick I'd like to set this up
with the observation that humans seem to
have a very hard time understanding the
population level consequences of
individual decisions in terms of
vaccines antibiotic resistance global
warming extinctions are all examples of
population level consequences of
individual decisions but that seems to
be paradoxical if we have been living in
stable Network since we were hunter
gatherers why aren't our minds better at
intuiting the things that you have to go
out and create a big complex research
program to discover okay so the question
was if in fact it's the case that uh
that humans have these effects on others
uh these externalities that we've been
discussing and if it's the case that
humans evolve a certain cognitive
equipment uh why doesn't our cognitive
equipment make us better able to avoid
the tragedy of the commons I think I
think that's a very deep question and I
only have a partial answer to give today
and the partial answer was be would be
that the evolutionarily relevant
environment in which we evolved uh was
actually very constrained it was a
face-to-face community and the and the
number of people that we actually
interacted with was on a much smaller
scale and uh that you know dunar for
example suggesting that it's about 150
people you look at the average size of
overnight camps in the anthropological
literature it's about 30 people these
people all knew each other I believe
those people actually could see the
externalities and could see that their
friends of friends were affected and
didn't have the reason to be aware of
the impact of their behavior on people
who were further away in the in the
geograph in the geodesic uh distance so
I think we have just enough cognitive
capacity to take into account the
externalities that affect the people
that are actually quite near us our
friends and maybe our friends of friends
and not enough cognitive capacity to
understand these other more complex
kinds of things so I think that's that's
part of the reason why we are so bad at
this and I think there's been I think
there's been a broadening I mean if if
you look at this the history history of
the world in the last 100 years there's
been a progressive broadening of in the
who counts as US versus them right so
initially it's just you know my my
little neighborhood you know my family
my neighborhood my nation there's a
globalization movement now in the 21st
I'm supposed to care about Unknown
People on another continent which was
not was an alien idea to people even 300
years ago animals we're supposed to care
about animals in a way like uh you know
we're extending moral rights to animals
there's a progressive expansion of what
who are the we that we care about about
now that is a kind of philosophical
cultural change that's still operating
with the kind of biological equipment
that's you know still back in the place
to scene um but but still must respect
that equipment in in some way so I think
that's part of the answer to your very
deep uh question is an incomplete answer
I
apologize yeah over here I have a
question about the Facebook study yes um
your talk is entitled that good and an
argument can be made that the
researchers were doing intervention for
entirely benign reasons uh even though
the users were not asked for permission
uh my question is given the fact that uh
the NSA and people like that have real
access to these networks uh how do we
know they're doing good things yeah so
the question has to do with the thing I
mentioned at the beginning the Dual use
implications of this so uh I didn't show
you today some of the work we've been
doing after the Fukushima
disaster there was a lot of
misinformation that was spreading in
Japan on the internet about the extent
of the radiation damage and everything
else and the Japanese government became
very concerned with how do we facilitate
the spread of true information that's
beneficial to people as compared to
false information that's causing alarm
and we've done some experiments and
there's I have a postto a graduate
student in my lab right now who's
working on similar topics of how to
manipulate information flow uh in
networks to kind of open up the gates to
let good information spread and Tamp
down the spread of bad information and
we begun to get calls by you know people
in orthod authoritarian countries that
are very interested in what we're doing
but not for the reasons that I care
about you know they obviously would be
interested in like let's say decreasing
voting and and reducing the spread but
this problem is not specific to the work
we do or even to the social sciences you
know there's a long history famously
here at Yale with Arthur gton you know
in the some of you know this case it's a
very moving case of a man working a
plant biologist working on the
exploration of plant hormones who later
on discovers that his work had been used
to in as a key ingredient and agent
orange and of course nuclear energy is
another classic example so there are
dual uses for this the same ideas that I
presented today to get developing World
villages to adopt clean water can be
used by Amazon to sell you you know more
widgets um so we're very mindful of this
you know we we and you know there's also
the case of the weaponization of
influenza that was in the news a year or
so ago but I don't have a complete
answer for you I mean it it it uh
there's no I wouldn't say that we should
shut down all search because some people
could use it for evil purposes but we're
aware that uh it can be uh exploited by
the way that experiment that with the
Facebook experiment was entirely ethical
it was approved by the IRB uh it has no
more than minimal risk there's studies
like that that are done all the time
including studies that involve
administration of of uh of
chemotherapeutic Agents
actually yeah over there um so I was
struck by the difference in the the
kinds of contagion where you had the
intervention the multivitamin
intervention versus the Clorox
intervention and you sort of attributed
it to different kinds of contagion yes I
I didn't attribute I I speculated I
don't know my question was well first as
a sort of anecdote to what degree could
you have predicted that fact the two
distinct outcomes of the two
interventions and sort of more generally
what do do we do we understand what the
distinction is between those two types
of contagion so that we can assess
whether a certain kind of process is
going to percolate through one or
through the other so the question had to
do is there any way that we can assess
uh exante what kind of processes are
more likely to percolate and that's also
a very deep question and is on the
frontier in my judgment right now and
I'm going to beg your permission and I'm
going to digress for two minutes to tell
you a little Fable that I think will
illustrate this point it's a bit off
color but I I think I can do it without
offending anyone so um now I have your
attention uh so imagine that you have
two islands in the Pacific and uh and
there are 100 people over here and 100
people over there there and on this
island everyone is having sex with
everyone else it's a fully saturated
graph there are 100 people 100 time 99
divided by two sexual inter counter it's
an org okay and over here there are 100
people and nobody's having sex with
anybody else they're all monks okay it's
a monastic environment now in Nei of
those two environments do you have an
epidemic of veneral diseases they're
fine these two worlds now a little
sailor washes up on shore and he has sex
with one person on this island or one
person on that island where do you get
the bigger
epidemic the one where everyone's having
sex with everyone else so the structure
of the graph is highly relevant to the
magnitude of the epidemic but there's no
epidemic unless the network is seated
the network must be seated once it's
seated the network magnifies what it's
seated with with me so far okay now
imagine that you have two different
islands everyone is having sex with
everyone else everyone is having sex
with everyone else now in these two
islands in both of them but here
everyone is immunocompetent their immune
systems work here everyone is immuno
compromised their immune systems do not
work sailor washes up on the shore where
do you get the bigger epidemic
imun a compromised one so it's not just
enough to know about the attributes of
the graph you have to know about the
attributes of the individuals you need
egocentric covariates that describe the
people also are relevant into whether
you get a spreading process in the graph
okay now I'm going to tell you a little
piece of biology this may be very useful
to you in your future life I don't know
if you have sex with someone who has
active syphilis you've got about a one
in three chance of Contracting syphilis
whereas if you have sex with someone who
has active HIV you've got about I'm a
physician so I can say these things
about one out of 500 chance of getting
HIV depending on the sexual act and a
number of other issues relating to viral
load and stuff so so now you have 100
people Everyone sex with everyone else
everyone's immunocompetent 100 people
Everyone sex with everyone else
immunocompetent sailor washes up on
shore here he has syphilis here he has
HIV where do you get the bigger epidemic
syphilis so it's not just the graph it's
not just the people it's the thing
itself that also determines the
spreading Dynamics now in the case of
microbiology we've got a hundred years
of knowledge that can shed light exan of
about the spreadability of these
pathogens how immunogenic are they how
big are they what do we know about
whether they express hydrophilic or
hydrophobic proteins on their surfaces
and so forth but in the case of things
like ideas or movies or public health
interventions we don't have that
knowledge yet we don't actually know how
spreadable things are and if you think
for instance about movies in other work
we've done we've looked at the Cascade
of movie uh appeal in networks it's one
thing to talk about how good a movie is
you can form an opinion of whether it's
a good or bad movie but a dis think
attribute of the movie is whether you
inform your friends about it and you
might do that whether it's a this a
terrible movie or you might see a
terrible movie you not tell anyone about
it or this is a good movie and you might
tell them or not so the spreadability of
the pathogen is different than the uh
The lethality of the pathogen and the
spreadability of a movie is different
than the quality of the movie and so
exanti I can't tell you uh what these
things uh do we can theorize and there
are some domains in which there is such
Theory so we are EX post speculating
about some of these things did I answer
your
question sort of yeah other question yes
in the back yeah kind of abstract
question the last few slides about value
you talked about taking a farest making
a farm you have more value but you have
more readily measurable value but we're
sort of in the case of farest learning
now that actually they have a lot of
value that's hard to measure and I don't
completely understand the translation
between that Social Capital but I wonder
if there are easier forms of Social
Capital to measure and through
intervention you might lose less readily
measurable forms of Social Capital so I
think if I've understood your question
correctly the concern is about just to
pick the farm example so I very
blly stated that the farm was more
valuable than the forest but of course
it depends on what you're trying to do
if you want wood clearing the forest was
a really stupid thing so it depends on
your objective function it depends on
what is your object Ive like what are
you actually trying to achieve so the
value of the thing depends in part on
what you're trying to achieve and the
same thing happens with social networks
if I'm trying to arrange you guys in a
fashion that makes you optimal for the
spread of information like I'm saying
okay I need to arrange these people in a
way so that if I give a piece of
information to one person it's going to
quickly spread through everyone that's
great but then oops that's terrible if
pathogens are spreading that same
structure is actually really bad if now
I'm trying to prevent the spread of
pathogens so actually to specify
uh what type of social Arrangement is
optimal requires you to specify what it
is that you're trying to achieve it's
our contention that across evolutionary
time there's been a kind of integration
across all of these things that you know
that there's kind of a just right kind
of an arrangement of social Arrangement
that is really good for the spread of
information but not so good that it
facilitates the spread of pathogens
that's really good for supporting
cooperation but not so good that it uh
it it reduces or increases redundancy of
information uh in the gra
so that there's a kind of balance we
think that has been achieved and so in
the social capital example if I've
understood your question the argument
would be that that certain types of
arrangements are very good for
maximizing certain kinds of Social
Capital but might actually be horrible
from another point of view and the
example that comes to mind is Nazism in
in um in the second world war right the
same social networks that can serve the
purpose of getting us to reinforce
desirable properties can whip people
into a frenzy right and get people to
act in really horrible uh and violent
ways and that would be a kind of capital
but put to bad
ends uh yes in the frontier yeah um one
one of the issues um in um I forget
which experiment we was indirect
reciprocity and so when we look at
indirect reciprocity it's easy to
explain in hunter gatherer groups where
it's coming from from Ken relationships
when we move out of there for example uh
aor and scientist try you know explain
that that what made it possible for us
to have uh reciprocity in strangers is
belief in moral Gods who were sort of
being part of our social network or
looking over our shoulder and so forth
but it looks like we do care about
reciprocity from people who are
strangers yes not just our social
network yes do you have any thoughts of
explaining that we do we've done some
work on that first of all on the god
example uh I'm not an expert in this
area exper in God but uh uh but there's
an enormous literature of perhaps you
know it uh on uh certainly on the
philosophy of religion but also on the
history of religion on the anthropology
religion on the biology religion one set
of ideas which I think might has a lot
of Merit is a set of ideas that imagines
that our the emergence of a religious
sensibility in human beings was grafted
onto our sociality so imagine that that
uh that uh you and I share a belief in a
deity let's let's imagine the deities
that that light over there uh but I
don't know you if you and I both believe
in the same God we've now become friends
of a friend right so you're now suddenly
two degrees removed from me via this
other uh entity this other node on the
network so if you imagine putting God in
the network all of a sudden everyone is
connected to the same God so now you can
feel a kinship to other people who who
believe in the same deity as you do but
that belief system that kinship the
utility of the religion is grafted onto
what used to be a kind of social
function which is that you and I would
uh be friends with each other so this
friendliness that we might feel uh among
strangers uh has been as a result of
religion has been actually grafted onto
a friendliness we might have felt not
among strangers originally so they're
bunch of people advancing these
ideas uh of of your religion um what was
the other thing you said um there was
something else I wanted to say but I I
spaced on it belief in moral in moral
Gods uh I can't remember strangers
versus friends oh friends yes so we've
been doing some work which I didn't show
you today that's looking at um
uh let me just summarize it very quickly
by just saying that what our work has
suggested is that the people you choose
as your friends share more uh leic
variance with you are more like you
genetically than uh than individuals you
choose as not your friends drawn from
the same population so what we think is
happening this is a big speculation it's
a big leap from the data that we have
and that we show is that people it is
believed by many and I share that belief
that human beings have a kinship
detector this has been shown in other
animals it's the evidence is weaker in
humans but I think we probably do have
the ability to distinguish kin from
non-kin but I think we have come to
apply that apparatus to the selection of
our friends so what happens when you go
out and pick from among a population of
strictly unrelated IND individuals who
should be your friend you tend to pick
people who actually share a lot of
genetic information in common with you
even though they're not your friends and
once you do that then all of the
apparatus for kin selection and
everything else can come into play
because from the point of view of a gene
if you help uh another human being who
shares that variant of that Gene even
though that person is unrelated to you
that's all that matters that you're
advancing the propagation of that
variant independent of whether that
variant was acquired by that person by
descent because you're relative
or otherwise so we we have some very
speculative ideas and some evidence that
actually your way of choosing friends
and your ability to help your friends
who are even strictly unrelated is also
grafted onto a whole other set of ideas
quite independent of of of religion so
you see I was right we're genetically
Yes actually and now now actually
there's there actually but but appr
propo of that there are a number of
possible reasons we all share we all of
us share more genetic variance than
chance part of that may be because we're
smart and have been recruited to Yale so
we have those in common part of it may
be uh because we were not recruited by a
higher power to come here uh but rather
um uh we sought this environment out so
independent of the agency of anyone else
we sought out this environment so
imagine that you have genetic variant
that make you an effective Runner and
you go to a place where you find other
people who are running and that's the
people from whom you choose to be
friends with it shouldn't be a shocker
that you share genes in common with
those people and the third mechanism
might be the affirmative Choice the
execution of choice from a group of
people who do uh spend time with so yes
I think Lyn is exactly right so just one
more question but I can tell you we have
a reception waiting for you in the
common room so you'll get a chance to
ask all the remaining questions so last
question you can pick oh my God you pick
I I I can't see any of but who's that
person in the middle there yes she he or
she looks like a younger person than the
others thank you there we go I'm trying
to bias towards anyone who plausibly is
a student I can't really tell so my
question is um how do things like um
culture or material uh aspects like
class into this like in terms of things
that can also configure social yes yes
I'm so glad you mentioned that thank you
so much so I'm often so the question was
what about things like uh like uh
culture and class and how they help
determine many of the same topics that
I've discussed today so I'm often
misunderstood when I talk about this
work as being a genetic determinist I'm
not I mean I think there's an equally
important role for culture um so I think
there's a kind of as you surely are
aware you know this endless debate
between nature and nurture and I just
think any kind of it's a silly dichotomy
I mean they're both important and uh and
so what I've been presenting today is
the ways in which our social structure
depends on to the extent we can
ascertain our biology but equally our
social structure depends hugely on our
culture for example if you go to Saudi
Arabia you're not going to find a lot of
friendships between men and women that's
got nothing to do with their biology of
the people in Saudi Arabia it's got
everything in my opinion to do with the
culture of the people there which
prohibit those types of you know of uh
interactions so the social structure
there would be different than here but
but what I'm interested in and what I'm
one of the things that I'm interested in
is trying to get at what I would regard
to be sort of very deep and
fundamental um aspects of human biology
or our our um inheritance you know from
our primate Forbe s that help shape the
kind of uh social phenomena that we
observe today and and in so doing I I
mean no disrespect to the equally
important cultural explanations note
that even when I talked about the
variance only 46% of the variance or 47%
of the variance and how many friends you
have was even upper limit was determined
by your genes the majority the slight
majority had to do with other things how
you were reared where you were reared
who your parents were your class and all
of those other phenomena so they're not
mutually exclusive did I answer your
question yeah so the reception is in the
Google common room which if you go out
and turn left it's just a little ways
down the hall thank thank you thank you
thank
you